what kind of style you know are you
gonna bring
to the big apple a lot of dunks
what's up everybody taylor brooks and we
are about to get real
and i'm ob topping and it's about to get
real ob
you know i would say welcome to new york
but this
is your home so i guess welcome back to
new york
this has to feel like it was destiny
right yes
for sure like i don't know if you guys
seen the picture but i was wearing this
freewell jersey number eight
and then i got picked number eight went
to new york so it was
it was crazy yeah what does the next
generation look like for the knicks
and how do you as a team get there a lot
more wins
we definitely get into the playoffs we
need to get to the playoffs
like everybody's bought into what coach
is saying this year they're pushing us
every single day holding us to a high
standard they're putting us through
everything that they need to put us
through to to be able to
be a championship caliber team and i
feel like everybody this year has bought
into what coach is saying which is
defense
defense defense when you were growing up
whose game did you really try to
replicate
is there anybody that sticks out
honestly my dad's like my dad's played
basketball
uh through college he played
professional basketball and he played
with uh street ball teams um
like for kings
i just feel like growing up watching him
play like i resembled my game
how did growing up around that street
ball impact the way that you play today
having a little bit of the guard skills
and and being
being able to play in front of large
crowds and people screaming
like if you mess up there you're gonna
hear it right after the game everybody
can just come up to you yes you're like
outside of the garden
where it is really real which is worse
getting dunked on or getting crossed up
i'll probably say again dunked on just
because it probably
hurts a lot more i'm not gonna lie i was
in i was in the bahamas my first year
playing
playing against oklahoma and someone did
me bad that game
and i did not touch on that whole night
what are some things that have
contributed to this relentless style of
play that we see from you
on the court doing the right things are
off the court honestly like i have to
eat good just because like
you want to fuel your body with with
good things drinking the right things
definitely vote 24 what you feel your
body with is going to help you on the
court
now you're in the nba about to play for
the next going to be in the garden
what kind of style you know are you
going to bring
to the big apple a lot of dunks
definitely team basketball like team
basketball sharing the ball
and just making making extra plays for
for not only ourselves but
our teammates too so we're gonna we got
fun this year
this was so much fun thank you to both
24 and obie i look forward to watching
you this season
yes thank you so much we definitely
gotta do a chip both cheers